vladimir putin is a very smart man
the western leaders by and large are
very stupid men
i'm not i'm not making a value judgment
i'm not i'm not ascertaining or
comparing the character the virtues of
this world i'm just
making an obvious observation vladimir
putin is smarter than western leaders
donald trump made that observation at
cpac
and it got him into a whole lot of hot
water
yesterday reporters asked me if i
thought president putin was smart
i said
of course he's smart to which i was
greeted with oh that's such a terrible
thing to say
i'd like to tell the truth yes he's
smart
the nato nations and indeed the world
as he
looks over what's happening
strategically
with no repercussions or threats
whatsoever they're not so smart
they're looking the opposite of smart if
you take over ukraine
we're going to sanction you they say
sanction
well that's a pretty weak statement
putin is saying oh they're going to
sanction me they sanctioned me for the
last 25 years you mean i can take over a
whole country are they going to sanction
me
you mean they're not going to blow us to
pieces at least psychologically
the problem
is not that putin is smart
which of course he's smart but the
real problem is that our leaders are
dumb
100
correct
it's funny that people accuse donald
trump of being prideful haughty
irresponsible reckless boastful
he's demonstrating a great deal of
wisdom and humility in this statement
wisdom and humility that our current
leaders don't have
ironically it's our current leaders joe
biden not the least of them who are
demonstrating the haughtiness the
recklessness the irresponsibility
in underestimating vladimir putin
ukraine is in this situation today
because western leaders for a long time
but mostly democrats and especially joe
biden
underestimated vladimir putin donald
trump is giving the devil his due he's
saying no look this guy he's clever he's
smart he's going to
pursue what he feels to be in the
national interest of russia
he's got cojones gotta you gotta give
him that he's got cojones he's not he's
going to call nato's bluff he's going to
call the american bluff and we're not
going to do anything about it we're not
even going to institute real sanctions
we're going to we're going to put little
fake sanctions on russia that won't do a
damn thing to to
to really gut their economy if you
really wanted to get their economy you
could put much stiffer sanctions
obviously on the energy industry on
specific oligarchs who are holding
vladimir putin's money but they're not
they're not exactly doing that at least
not yet
our
leaders
are dumb
they're they're so dumb that our leaders
are so dumb they are making the best
argument to support putin
i don't think putin is making a very
good argument to support putin putin is
a sort of cartoonishly villainous figure
and he's now invading this country and
the war is obviously being brought by
him i don't think it's very complicated
as to who is bringing this war
and yet western leaders are so stupid
that they that they have to clutch
defeat from the jaws of victory even on
the publicity front i'm so glad you like
that clip you know by the way if you
want to watch me compete against the big
boss himself ben shapiro we've got a new
episode of face off
famous dead guys edition
listen i've gone up against dave rubin
i've gone up against matt walsh now i'm
going up against ben himself the results
i don't want to spoil anything the
results might surprise you go check out
that episode go subscribe to the michael
knowles show at apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]